ich habe einmal zu sophia thomalla bezug
genommen die hatte ein freund loris
karius der bei union berlin im tor stand
das heißt stand ich im tor sondern saß
auf der bank und ich hab dann in dem
kommentar gesagt naja für eine kuschel
nacht mit sophia thomalla würde mich
auch auf die bank setzen da hatte ich
einen sexismus shitstorm ohne ende und
damals wollte mich schon raus werfen
aber eben auch das finde ich daneben
bitter dass ein so großer konzern so
sich von twitter orientieren lässt und
dadurch schon gehandelt hat und dann war
eine situation dass ein japaner aufs tor
geschossen hat und da habe ich dann
formuliert das wäre sein erster treffer
in deutschland gewesen den letzten hat
er im land der sufis erzielt da kann
aber auch abfällig damit japaner gemeint
haben aber das lag mir total fern und
völliger blödsinn wie so was
unterstellen
[Musik]